i ran across a passage recently that i
was completely startled by it's in
hermann melville's book marty
which is his youthful travel
journals around the southeast before he
got into the big guns
and but at one point in marty there's a
discussion among some semen on the deck
of a ship
about the future and one of them is
asking you know what is the what does it
mean what is the future
and this seaman looks up and he says
the future his little hieroglyphics
very very prescient comment
because as we see we now know we are
code
we are dna code we're about to build
a civilization made of code in vrml
and we are learning uh you know
languages
like pearl and c plus plus
and so in a sense the future is
all hieroglyphic
the world is all deception it's some
kind of a
koan or a problem or a labyrinth or a
thing to be seen
through and if you don't
figure it out you would take it to be
real
and then you know it shunts you into the
yawning grave
but if you can somehow realize that the
purpose of your existence
is to figure it out and then figure it
out
you will be in some sense liberated from
it
there's a wonderful science fiction
story that i remember from
years and years ago i can't remember the
name of it but it's by
uh robert heinlein and it's about a man
who
uh he's some kind of
commuter some dullard but as he leaves
his house one morning on a way to his
daily job
he looks down at the edge of his lawn
and a worm crawls out of the ground that
has
these golden pearlescent wings
and it flies off and it's just this
completely improbable thing like a
hallucination
and then later in the day uh and he says
to himself it's an
angel worm it's an angel worm
and then later in the day something else
happens i can't remember
and then later in the day something else
equally improbable
and in the evening he's sitting
considering these three unlikely things
and he realizes that
the e-mat has slipped
in the cosmic book
and that he was supposed to see an angle
worm
but he saw an angel worm because the e
had jumped position
in the line of type that was describing
what was going on
and then he begins to pay more and more
attention and he realizes then that he
can
find these typographical errors in
reality
uh well i only like the story for the
idea that the
the world is made of elements that are
completely hidden from us
and don't betray themselves unless
there's a glitch
in the assembly languages in the deeper
levels of the system
and that's the resin better for probing
the edge
because those are like benchmark
tests for the cybernetic system we're in
you know you want to push it to the
limit of course the system can add
two and two but you know can it carry
out these
complex factorial processes where
if we're being shocked and jived it
might betray itself
so the technique then is to keep
keep looking for just to [ __ ] in the
door
just one way in and psychedelics are it
as far as i can tell and then of course
some
psychedelics uh more than others
but more and more i have this intuition
that the world is like a literary
construction
of some sort that this this is much more
like a novel
than it is like the world of physics and
entropy and equilibrium
that we're cheerfully assured we should
believe it is
because what we feel in our own lives i
think
is the invisible hand of an author
moving us to this affair this decision
to move this career choice this drug
trip uh so forth and so on i mean
it is a very authored feeling
to reality and it hints
that as it says in moby dick
all visible things are but as pasteboard
masks
if you would strike strike through the
mask
[Music]
you